المحافظه وانفجار هائل كبير الان نحن الان
انفجار انفجار يمكنكم ان تشاهدوا هذا
الانفجار هذا الانفجار التو حدث الانجار
عنيفه تحول البحر الاحمر الى ساحه
تصعيد بالتاكيد لن اتحدث عن العمليات
العسكريه المستقبليه ما رايتموه كان مجرد
الجوله الاولى معارك البحر الاحمر تنطفئ
فيما الصين تعلن تدخلها باسطول البحري
بينما البيت الابيض يكشف عن حل جذري
لانهاء الحرب وعرض مغر تضعه تل ابيب على
طاوله السيسي فهل تقبل القاهره وطائرات
البيرقدار التركيه تنضم الى اسطول مصر
الجوي دونالد ترامب يفشي اسرارا خطيره
ويضع النتنياهو في موقف محرج وجو بايدن
يطالب من سلطاته بسرعه التحضر لحرب وشيكه
في الشرق الاوسط الجيش الامريكي يشن ضربات
انتقاميه جديده وانزال جوي اردني هولندي
في القطاع بريطانيا تسحب حامله طائراتها
في مناورات النيتو والمانيا تعقد ضمانات
امنيه لاوكرانيا وحيله ماكره من زيلينسكي
للتخلص من تهمه اسقاط الطائره الروسيه
هنغاريا تكشف موقفها من الصراع في
اوكرانيا البحريه الصينيه
تتدخل معارك الضربات تشتعل في البحر
الاحمر وهجمه من هنا ورد من هناك بعد
غارات امريكيه بريطانيه جديده على مناطق
عديده في مدينه الحديده غربي اليمن افادت
وسائل اعلام يمنيه بان واشنطن ولندن شنت
ثلاث غارات على شرق مدينه صعده هنا كان
المتحدث باسم الجيش اليمني يحيى سريع قد
صرح ان عدد الضربات الامريكيه على اليمن
بلغ 48 مشيرا الى انها استهدفت عده
محافظات في البلاد واكد انها لن تمر دون
رد وعقاب هناك اعلنت القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه تدمير صاروخ مضاد للسفن كان
مجهزا للاطلاق من مناطق سيطره حكومه صنعاء
في اليمن كما اعلن الجيش الامريكي تدمير
ست صواريخ كروز تابعه للجيش اليمني كانت
معده للاطلاق ضد صفن تجاريه بالبحر الاحمر
لتجد الصين الحل لسفنها حيث بدات البحريه
الصينيه بمرافقه سفن الشحن الصينيه عبر
البحر الاحمر وفقا لشركه شحن وتقارير
وسائل اعلام رسميه الصينيه ياتي ذلك في
الوقت الذي قررت فيه العديد من شركات شحن
البضائع تجنب الممر التجاري المهم عالميا
بسبب هجمات اليمنيين وهنا يتحدث المصدر
بدات البحريه الصينيه بمرافقه سفل الشحن
الصينيه عبر الممر المائي وفيما قررت
العديد من شركات شحن البضائع تجنب الممر
التجاري بسبب هجمات الحوثيين فيما اكد
الناطق باسم حكومه صنعاء محمد عبد السلام
في حسابه على منصه اكس ان استمرار الهجوم
الامريكيه البريطانيه على اليمن لن يحقق
لهما اي هدف بل يزيد من مازق ومشاكلهم على
مستوى المنطقه واضاف عبد السلام وبشان
القدرات اليمنيه العسكريه نحب ان نؤكد انه
ليس من السهل تدميرها وقد اعيد بناؤها في
ظل سنوات حرب قاسيه لننتقل الى الداخل
الامريكي حيث اعلن البيت الابيض رفض
الاداره الامريكيه مشروع قانون مجلس
النواب بشان تقديم المساعده العسكريه
الجديده الى تلبيب دون مساعدات اضافيه
لاوكرانيا فيما صرح البيت الابيض انه على
المدى الطويل للسلام في المنطقه ولامن
التلبيب في المنطقه هو حل الدولتين من
جهته هاجم الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب ضمنيا رئيس الوزراء العبري بنيامين
نتنياهو قائلا ان تلبيب شاركت للتخطيط
لاغتيال قائد الحرس الثوري الايراني قاسم
سليماني لكنها تراجعت في اللحظه الاخيره
واضاف الرئيس الامريكي السابق وفي مقابله
مع قناه فوكس نيوز قلت للجنرال لنفعلها
لكن تلبيب كانت جزءا من ذلك النتنياهو كان
جزءا كبيرا من الامر وقمنا بالتخطيط لكل
شيء هنا ابلغ الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
مجلس النواب بانه سيوجه الجيش باتخاذ
تدابير اضافيه ضد الحرس الثوري الايراني
والفصائل المرتبطه به اذا دعت الضروره
فيما صرح مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جيك سيلوفان لشبكه ان بي سي بان رد واشنطن
لن يقتصر على جولت القصف الحاليه في سوريا
والعراق واليمن بل تعتزم تنفيذ ضربات
انتقاميه اضافيه وذلك لتوضيح ان الولايات
المتحده تردوا على الهجمات ضد قواتها وعلى
قتل شعبها وفق تعبيره بالعوده الى القطاع
حيث نفذ الاردن وهولندا انزال جويا على
المستشفى الميداني في القطاع ولنتصور
في تل ابيب افادت القناه 12 العبريه بان
اس وترتش طالب البنوك العبريه بعدم تطبيق
العقوبات الامريكيه على المواطنين بينما
احتشد الاف المتظاهرين العبريين المناهضين
لحكومه النتنياهو في تل ابيب للمطالبه
باستقاله الحكومه الحاليه وفي مصر كشف
مسؤول عبري لوكاله رايترز ان الجيش سينسق
مع مصر لبحث سبل اجلاء معظم النازحين
باتجاه شمال قبل اي زحف بري في رفح وكانت
مصادر عبريه كشفت ان تلبيب عرضت على
القاهره نقل موقع معبر رفح الى المثلث
الحدودي العبري المصري مع القطاع ووفقا
لهذه المصادر العبريه فان القاهره لم ترد
على هذا المقترح ولنضع لكم المصدر ام دعني
ابدا معك بهذا المقترح الذي قدمته او تقول
اسرائيل انها قدمته للقاهره بنقل معبر رفح
الى المثلث الحدودي المصري الاسرائيلي مع
قطاع غزه اما في تركيا فقال وزير الخارجيه
التركي هاكان فيدان ان تركيا وافقت على
تزويد مصر بطائراتها المسيره التي تحظى
بشعبيه متزايده بعد تطبيع العلاقات بين
البلدين بعد قطيعه دامت عقدا وبعيدا عن
الشرق الاوسط اعلنت البحريه الملكيه
البريطانيه ان حامله الطائرات كوين
اليزابيث التي كان من المقرر ان تقود اضخم
مناورات لحلف النتو منذ الحرب البارده لن
تشارك في المناورات بسبب خلل
القاني المجر
تنسحب هنغاريا او المجر كما يقولها العرب
شكلت غصه في حلق اوروبا وعائقا لاوكرانيا
لكن هنا قال وزير خارجيه هنغاريا بيتر
سيارتو في مقابله مع قناه في ار تي
التلفزيونيه ان بلاده اعربت بوضوح عن
موقفها لروسيا فيما يتعلق بالصراع في
اوكرانيا ودانت استمرار الاعمال القتاليه
ودعت الى وقف اطلاق النار وبدء المفاوضات
واشار سيرتو الى ان المجره لن تمنع زياده
ميزانيه صندوق السلام الاوروبي لمساعده
اوكرانيا لكنه قال ان بودابيست لن تشارك
في القرار المتعلق بنقل الاسلحه الى
القوات الاوكرانيه من جهتها افادت صحيفه
فاز الالمانيه بان برلين وكيف قد تعقدان
اتفاقا مشتركا حول ضمانات امنيه ثنائيه
خلال مؤتمر ميونخ الالماني المقرر عقده في
الس 16 ع من فبراير وهنا نتصفح
[موسيقى]
المصدر في امريكا ذكرت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز ان قاده النيتو يبحثون بشكل غير
رسمي مصير التحالف في حال فاز دونالد
ترامب بالانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
وبحسب صحيفه تساءل المسؤولون وخصوصا
الالمان فيما اذا كان التحالف سيستمر اذا
سحب ترامب عضويه الولايات المتحده من
النيتو ولم تعد الدوله محور التحالف في
اجواء الحرب الاوكرانيه قال مستشار الامن
القومي للرئيس الامريكي جيك سيلوفان ان
الولايات المتحده لن تتدخل في حاله اقاله
زالو جيني مؤكدا ان اتخاذ قرار كهذا حق
سيادي لرئيس اوكرانيا فلاديمير زيلينسكي
وفي وقت سابق ذكرت صحيفه واشنطن بوست نقلا
عن مصادر ان كياف ابلغت البيت الابيض بان
زيلينسكي قرر اقاله زالو جني ولم تؤيد
واشنطن القرار لكنها لم تطعن فيه بينما
قالت صحيفه بوليتيكا الصربيه ان الرئيس
الاوكراني زيلنسكي ينوي اتهام القائد
العام للقوات الاوكرانيه فاليري زالو جني
باسقاط طائره الاسرى الاوكرانيين
[موسيقى]
الروسيه